networks economics
um
more more time on the economics um to
begin with so i'll give you a little bit
of economic background and then that'll
set up
a learning model
and i'm going to start here
um just with background on homophily and
and so
one thing that's extremely important in
in predicting economic outcomes seems to
be how split graphs are so what's the
strongest split you can find in terms of
a graph and
this is um
a picture of a high school each one of
these little dots is a student
and they're color coded by race in this
case
and um
the line between two students indicates
that they're connected in terms of
naming each other as people that did at
least three activities in a given week
so this is for mad health and what you
see is that there's a pretty strong
split so this is just drawn with a
spring algorithm
so it's it pulls together nodes that are
connected pushes them apart if they're
not connected and you can begin to see
that even though this school is fairly
racially
diverse
when you actually look it's integrated
on paper but when you actually look at
the friendship patterns it's heavily
segregated and so one thing we want to
understand is what are the implications
of these kinds of splits and graphs that
you see so this is from the add health
data um this is from a study with uh
sergio cruz and paulo pin
um you can also see this this is from
another study we did in
karnataka southern india this is a
village
these are households now and this is a
kerosene and rice sharing network so
this is um you know people borrow and
lend kerosene and rice
in this case the nodes are now colored
by cast
so the
um
red dots are
scheduled cast and scheduled tribes
which are relatively disadvantaged cast
groups the blue squares are
um uh general merit and otherwise
backward casts and relatively advantaged
casts so here again you see in this case
there's about a 15 times higher
chance that two nodes are connected if
they're of the same cast designations
and you can run you know community
detection algorithms on this as well and
you'll see that there's additional
splits among the scheduled cast and
scheduled tribes
you know the characteristics of the
persons on the
boundaries to community
oh yes actually um we do so
i mean i can tell you some anecdotal
stories about those
um they actually tend so you know
there's a theory in sociology uh ron
burch's bridges between communities tend
to do very well
in these communities they actually tend
to be marginalized
individuals so often they're
widowed households
uh other kinds of so when you look at
these households they don't tend to be
the higher uh
households in terms of wealth or other
um characteristics they tend to be
somewhat peculiar households for one
reason or another um
but there's you know there's interesting
patterns i
those data are actually available on the
web if you want to play with them so we
have
um
75 different villages
uh you can look at the structure of
these
but this kind of homophily is something
that's quite prevalent it's there in a
lot of different settings
and it has consequences
and one of the consequences i want to
talk about is
economic inequality and immobility and
i'm going to show you some data about
that in a moment and then we'll talk
about how network models can help us you
know help inform us about these kinds of
issues and and why we might think that
this is related to networks and i think
over time
i've become convinced that in terms of a
social scientist perspective you know
these understanding these splits in the
graph and understanding these hemophilia
structures
is really fundamental to understanding
why we have strong divisions inequality
polarization other kinds of things in
the society so i think it's a
fundamental um a fundamental driver of
these things and and i think it's you
know part of the reason for spending
today's lecture on this is is to try and
understand some of the consequences
um
so one other piece of background things
to keep in the back of your head what's
known as the gatsby curve so this is
something that was popularized by ellen
krueger in a presentation to obama in
2012 i want to say
and what this is is it looks at two
different things
so it's looking at immobility on this
axis so immobility is what's the chance
that a pair a child looks different than
the parent so immobility is correlation
between child's income and parents
income so in particular it's a law
coefficient on a log log regression so
it's basically a correlation coefficient
of how correlated is a child's income
with a parent so really high correlation
means that once i see your parent i know
how you're going to end up in your
future so
if things are fair um you should see
pretty much zero correlation between
parent and child income if things are
unfair you know the parent's income
determines the child's income
and then on the other end
index here is the genie index of
inequality and this is an index which
basically asks you know if you randomly
pick two individuals from the society um
how much more wealth with the
the the richer person have compared to
the poorer person and if that's zero
then there's pretty much even
income distribution across the society
if it's one then basically the richer
person would have you know 100 of the
wealth and so what you see here
is that countries that have higher
inequality also have higher immobility
this also works on microcosmic levels so
if you look within the united states you
look at this by zip code you look at it
by county you'll see a similar pattern
the counties that have the most
inequality have the most of mobility
okay and and part of the reason that
this is interesting is
networks
you know naturally have these kinds of
feedback features or if you're in a sort
of a bad position in a network and you
you aren't getting resources you're not
getting information you're not getting
things then that can perpetuate itself
and so
when you look at network models they
tend to have the feature that they'll
give you both of these things at the
same time okay so that's just another
thing to keep in the back of your mind
okay um
next piece of information economic
information to keep track of is the
geography of upward mobility in the
united states
so this is a map of
you know just looking at a person look
at a kid
in the 25th percentile of the income
distribution in terms of their parents
income so this is a person who's in the
poor quarter of the society and then ask
what's their income going to be when
they grow up okay and so this is data
from
raj chetty and a team of researchers
from 2018 and this is just a map by the
u.s
and you know there's a huge amount of
variation so these are just average
incomes and what you'll notice is that
there's geographic patterns to some of
this so there's whole parts of the
country where kids that grow up in the
bottom part of the income distribution
are going to stay there other parts
where they tend to rise out of um
yeah so north dakota and south dakota
are fascinating um places and and you'll
see that popping up in a bunch of maps
i'm going to show you a little in a
couple of minutes um so that you know
actually the this whole part of the
upper middle west is um is is high on
pretty much a whole bunch of of
scales in the middle of this um those
are actually native american
reservations
um reports and zones are made for
american reservations
i don't know maine that well so i can't
tell you exactly what but that's fine
it's
um yes
uh how does it take into account actual
mobility of people moving from the
states is it the state of the parent or
the state of a child so this is actually
looking at a child's income and it could
be that the child ended up in a
different place so this is looking at
the place where the child grew up and
then eventually um just asking where
what their income ended up being so it
can also be that some of the children
here stayed in this area and some of the
children here actually moved to new york
or moved to you know san francisco bay
area so so it's not um so there is
mobility as part of this and i can tell
you there's a lot of interesting things
about um income and mobility um that
take us way off uh off topic but
it's important and what's going on i'm
guessing that this is somehow normalized
for the face of life for the parents
where and where they are right now
yes so this is done this is looking at
uh age 35
um of people in 2014 so it's looking at
one slice of
people and it's
um you can do this in different scales
this is actually in actual dollar scales
household incomes but you can also do it
in in relative um you know just
percentiles in the u.s and so forth that
there's cost of living other kinds of
issues that are going on there's lots of
things to take into consideration that
i'm not gonna try and get into but
average income of the jobs when these
children are high or the average should
so you know so this is take all the take
the um children whose parents earned 27
000 when they were kids
but so take the kid
so take them sorry take a 35 year old
now in 2014 look at when they were a
child
ask what their parents income was
look at all the kids whose parents
income were 27 000 when they were a kid
and now i ask what the current kids
income is
and and that's what this this number is
so these are all kids who had parents
who had the same income when they were
kids and then looking at the the kids
income when they were when they're
adults
and so you see a huge amount of
variation across the universe
okay so um
part part of the reason for being
interested in this
is that you know again
inequality mobility norms jobs learning
are all impacted by homophobia and i'll
talk a little bit about more you know
about why we care about these kinds of
structures in the networks and why that
might be related to this and so this
afternoon i'm going to do this a little
more background and homophily and then
we're going to look at a particular
learning model and part of the reason
for looking at that learning model is
it's a nice model in terms of
capturing how homophily relates to the
specific outcomes but i think it's a
metaphor for a lot of other dynamic
processes on networks that would have
some similar features so it's you know
sort of a
an example of of the kind of features
you might be interested in so next what
i'm going to do is show you um a paper
um actually data from a couple of papers
that we just released um these are with
raj chetty theresa cooper johannes
strobel and then a large team of people
this is on facebook data
we released these a few i guess
a few weeks ago now
and
it has a pretty rich set of data about
exactly what's going on in
um in the graphs and so forth so we can
understand the homophily we can
understand the consequences and i want
to show you some of those
okay so what we used in this in these
studies were
facebook users we did a cut in in may so
a couple of months ago was the last draw
of data we did um
ages we're going to look at people who
are 25 to 44 year olds that's because
most they have the really high usage and
were able to trace back to what their
parents income were when they were kids
and things like that so we can do things
from those from that slice of life
these are going to be active users with
at least 100 friends
so it's 72 million people 21 billion
friendships it's 84 of the coverage of
of you know people in the united states
um and then we have a lot of information
about them we have the friendships a lot
of demographics
geography memberships and different
groups heists where they went to high
school college
recreation groups it's churches etc
and then we're going to marry that with
census data and a bunch of other things
and
in terms of yeah sorry can you tell us
something about
which 70 million uscs are like how how
do you sample that yeah yeah um so
basically what we're using is so it's
it's anybody on facebook who is at least
30 day active and has at least 100
friends
um i have
did you
how did they get that data so
um
mike bailey um co-author here uh was a
student at stanford so basically raj and
i started talking about how do networks
impact mobility and economic outcomes um
mike bailey was someone we knew from
uh from him being a student stanford
theresa and johannes were also students
at stanford um they've been working with
facebook data so we teamed up and then
the list of large numbers of
incredibly useful and very hard working
co-authors were people who are basically
uh as you'll see doing different
measures on the on the data
in terms of the coverage of facebook
data so we're looking at pretty much
anybody who has a facebook account who
is 25 to 44 years old
and then
yeah so we look
how do we know what the age they are
literally everybody on there who fits
those criteria yeah exactly so it's a
full sample it's not like we're pulling
random yeah so it's it's it's pretty
much any so we're looking at 84 of the
us population between the ages of 25 and
40. you're saying that even though
everybody says but facebook is coming
out actually 84 percent of the u.s
population has more than 100 friends on
facebook and this act yeah of the 25 to
44 year olds so it's actually the
demographics are quite interesting so um
among people below 25 facebook is dying
out so
and we actually use instagram data to
look at younger people for part of the
study so we also use we looked at
younger people and made sure that the
things we produce with younger group
they're on instagram um so
you know it's very different by
different ages um usage patterns uh the
older people are also there but they
wouldn't be useful for the kinds of
questions we're gonna ask
yeah yeah but it's it there's a really
market drop off
it's like a cliff in terms of the age
dynamics
so that's 25 is the reason
okay so one key thing we're going to do
then is so one thing we do is we use a
series of machine learning techniques to
impute people's income
so we have uh we have information on
where people live and in a whole series
of things about them what kind of phone
they use what computers they use what
whether they went to college um you know
a bunch of stuff
we use that
and
we also have census income data so we
can pinpoint the income of the area they
grow up in and we basically train a
model to
to predict income
and so then from those income
designations what we're going to do is
look at economic homophily right so
before i showed you a picture of like
homophily across castes or homophily
across different ethnicities within a
high school what we're going to do is
take people who are in the bottom half
of the income distribution and ask how
connected are they to the people in the
top half of the income distribution okay
so we're just going to cut it in half
and then say
look at the bottom half of the
distribution economic connectedness is
number of friends with above median
income basically
over the total number of friends then
divided by a half so this should be a
half
right this ratio should be a half if you
just had a normal representative group
of friends
if this is bigger than a half it means
you're more connected to the rich if
it's smaller than a half you're less
connected
okay
so this is um first of all just the mean
if you look at somebody's rank in the
income distribution this is the rank of
their average rank of their friends
so
there's a lot of homophily
and
what one thing that we do is look at you
can look at top 10 friends as opposed to
all the friends so top 10 is based on
you know your interactions on facebook
whether you're posting and commenting on
each other and and so forth so it
doesn't really matter whether you're
looking at top 10 friends or others you
see strong commothly so the fact that
this is not a flat curve
is indicating that there's different
friendship patterns among the poor
compared to the rich
question
it's maybe because i'm 99 years old on
facebook
no um so i think i can tell you a lot
more offline about how we do that
um but there so there's a lot of so we
basically use 22 different variables
about a person
okay so so um the census data so take
the census data for instance uh let's
suppose you grew up um
you you live on
seventh street and third avenue in new
york
okay
yeah so we join those two things and
then we can take all the demographics
that we know about you plus your
geography predict your income so we
train a model based on that and then we
use it to impute these incomes
and then we actually match we check
whether or not this matches up with
census data and then a whole series of
other things that we know
do we know anything about the bias of
being on facebook
yes yeah yeah we have lots of long
appendix about that given the fact that
we have 84 of the population we
basically don't have much of a bias um
there's differences among the patterns
here but um i should just i'll i can
show you a graph later i have a graph of
the actual geographic coverage and the
geographic coverages is quite just like
a checkerboard there's no real pattern
to it so we don't see systematic biases
in the facebook coverage here we also
match this up with the add health data
and check that it looks like the
health data in terms of income
distributions and support it does seem
to match up so there's a lot of
robustness checks i think the data are
pretty good um you know we won't get
causal inference out here so we'll be
able to look at these and then i'll tell
you about what some of the outcomes are
and there'll be some questions here but
i think the quality of the data seems to
be pretty good
on some dimensions
we match people to high schools um guess
what the most popular high school in the
united states is on facebook
hogwarts um so you know you you need to
work a little bit on the data to
actually figure out what high school
people want to but it's possible um so
so there there's a lot of stuff that
yeah
i mean you can still figure it out
okay
um
this is the economic connectedness of
people
by um so this is actually uh by county
in the united states
and just to remind you this was the
upward mobility map and this is the
measure of homophily so you'll see that
you there's a pretty high correlation
between how connected the poor people
are to the wealthy people and whether or
not the poor people are later in life
ending up um wealthy right so these
what are these colors
so the colors i'm sorry so red if you
look at these economic connectedness
below 0.58 is the worst so these are
mean that um you're you know so if you
have a one that means that your
friendship patterns are
just like they would be at random so you
have 100 of the number of friends you
should have among the rich 58 percent
means you have only 58 of the number of
rich friends that you should have if you
were connecting to the rich at random
and rich you know direct to people at
random
um and then 1.05 is the top you get in
the data up again in the dakotas um
where you know you the the poor people
have uh over-representation of of
wealthy people in their networks
relative
so you see a pretty wide range
um one thing that's interesting and i
won't go i don't have maps to show you
all that but if you look at a particular
city if you look at for instance the bay
area you'll see very different patterns
within the bay area
so even though there's sort of broad
geographic patterns when you sort of
zero in you can see a lot of variation
on the local level
now
if you sort of cross these pictures now
it might matter that in certain areas
you have 40 percent of the users at
facebook
so overall
exactly yeah yeah and so we do a lot of
uh you know again i'm not going to go
into all the robustness checks we do on
that but um
that doesn't seem to matter here um so
we don't see a systematic measurement
error in that in that regard
okay so um then basic question is does
economic connectedness predict um
household income rank
uh in terms of you know take again these
poor kids so take a kid that grew up
where their parents were at the 25th
percentile ask what their eventual
income is so how wealthy are the poor
kids growing up to be and in places with
this less homophily so higher
connectedness you see higher mobility
places with low connectedness high
homophily you see um low mobility okay
so that's the basic relationship here
um
and then you can think of a bunch of so
here what we're looking at is economic
connectedness
you could think of lots of different
graph measures you might want to look at
in terms of the network so you've got
the facebook network you say what other
kinds of things might you want to look
at
okay well you could look at a bunch of
network measures clustering measures
like you know how many completed
triangles do you see in the network you
could look at spectral homophily so
um second eigenvector eigenvalue of the
stochastic sized version of the of the
matrix you can look at how many people
how many friendships have friends in
common
um
you can look at you know other versions
of connectedness age connectedness
instead of economics language
connectedness whether people went to
college are they connected across that
divide so there's a bunch of things you
can look at and then you can look at
other kinds of measures that people have
used you know non-network measures that
people look at like how what's the
volunteering rate in a given area what's
the participation in civic organizations
this is like putnam kind of stuff from
putnam's book so there's a whole series
of things you can look at
and
you know so clustering
support etc
so this was the economic connectedness
this was the upward mobility for
instance here's what the clustering
looks like by county
um so if you look at the clustering
ratio in the graph we remember
clustering is when you look at
when people have two friends what's the
probability that they're the frequency
with which their friends are friends
with each other so how completed how
locally clustered is the graph
um
that doesn't have the same pattern as
the other parts do
okay so there is a pattern to it but
it's a different pattern
yeah
yes exactly very very highly clustered
if you live in alaska you know all your
neighbors know each other
um
okay so here's the correlations between
upward mobility and these measures of
capital um so you can begin to see these
are just raw correlations so take all
these different you know whatever
measure you like
look at the economic connectedness and
basically this homophily measure does a
much better job at predicting this
economic mobility than the other
measures so that's part of the reason i
was saying that this kind of homophily
seems to be very important in at least
one economic outcome
so this you know we expected to see
different patterns here this was i think
a little surprising to us how strong
this was
um you can do a multivariate regression
and actually with a so this the raw
correlation is is about 0.64 to 0.67
depending on counting zips etcetera
when you look at the multivariate
regression it actually pops up a little
bit once you control for some of the
other measures
but the other measures in fact some of
them have negative
correlations and
uh there's some interesting things going
on okay so so
message one just is that this economic
connectedness seems to predict economic
mobility
um the other kind of thing is
you could ask whether or not
other
um
background things about the particular
community so how unequal is the income
distribution in the area places with big
big inequalities might have big
immobility so normally
the more income inequality you would
have the less mobility you would have so
if you just run a regression of upward
mobility on income inequality you get a
highly
significant coefficient but once you
control for economic connectedness that
pretty much disappears so the economic
connectedness seems to mediate
some of these other relationships that
are out there you can do the same thing
with
the share another thing variable that
people often use is
ethnic composition of the area so places
that
have high black
populations tend to have low mobility so
if you look at a raw correlation with
that there's a negative predictor the
more black people live in an area the
lower the mobility is but once you um
correct for connectedness that pretty
much disappears as well
um and the same thing with you know you
can do a bunch of different variables
um it's the same is true for upward
mobility for blacks or whites
um
okay
so
there's basically this pattern going on
and
um
you know we for instance it's not a
racial thing the united states is
heavily racially segregated
this is when you look at only counties
in the u.s where you have at least 90
percent of the population being white
you get the same relationships so it
seems that this homophily is still
predictive no matter where where you're
looking
yeah i'm a little bit
sort of trying to you know track my
video so you're measuring the social
capital right now
but upward mobility you know through the
time so how do you reconcile yeah
so
uh two things um
one
is what we we also do and i don't have
that regression right here but um
we can also look so
on facebook we can pair you with your
parents and we can look at your parents
income and then what we can look at is
how connected people are from
their income compared to their friends
parents income
and we can look at your high school
friends so go back look at your high
school friends parents income and then
see how well connected you are and see
how that predicts and so when we do that
we get pretty much the same regressions
out that we're looking at here so
whether we're doing this connectedness
across current income or whether we look
at people's high school parents friends
income we get the same relationships
um and so that's one of the checks that
it's not just
you know something about current income
that's that
is going on yeah
yes
yeah yeah so you can get um you can
download these um you can go to my
website you can download the
zip file with all of the
all these measures by zip code county
high schools and colleges in the u.s
and all of the
subsets not all those measures but you
can get about six or eight of the
measures
um
no we didn't do it by person and we
noised up the data so there's we had to
add epsilon noise to the data to release
it so it has a little bit of noise in it
depending on how big the county or the
school is and we do not have individual
identifiers in the data that we release
so it's all privacy
protected question returning to my
original question when you have a split
and there were these people in the
boundary
connecting to society then it is
reflected in this data as well those
whose parents were currently poor but
then they become richer have more
friends from the richard community do
you see that um so
yeah so we
we have not tracked individual
outcomes based on that so
we have
we have thought about ways to try and do
that we haven't looked at that
specifically yet um
so this is sort of the first release of
the data and we're still doing a lot of
studying and um
one of the things we want to look at is
more granular stuff on individual
okay um so different reasons so
basically in the background we've got
there's a lot of inequality it seems to
be related to mobility as well
there's reasons we might expect that
these kinds of splits in the graph would
matter and i just want to talk through a
couple of them really rapidly and then
i'm gonna spend some time on on the
learning model and try and see why these
kinds of splits make a difference and
i think of the sort of three different
types of of ways in which people you
know splits can matter
one is there's basic opportunities so
for instance you know many people get
jobs through networks and if your
friends are unemployed it's hard to get
a job and it's hard to get a job
interview so that's one thing and i've
actually
done work with nicole and another where
we have you know papers on how
networks
can lead to
inequality as a result of the
homophily there so job context these are
opportunities peer influences we talked
about that yesterday so pure effects um
choices complementarities if everyone in
my high school is dropping out and not
studying it's harder for me to study um
as a teenager and so that's going to be
another factor and then there's just
basic learning you know
is there information getting to me about
what is what i should be doing to get
into college or you know what
opportunities there are in terms of
fellowships or scholarships or you know
various things like that is that
information getting to me or is it stuck
somewhere else in the network so these
are three basic ways in which you know
these kinds of things can matter
very carefully using words like uh
forces uh explanatory factor you never
say causality that's for the reason that
you're not playing the causality here or
it's causality
yeah so there's certain things that we
can claim causality about
and a lot that we can't so a lot of the
stuff that i showed you is correlational
and predictive so it's it's you know
observational data and we don't have
experiments what we are doing now is
we're tracking you so you can track kids
for instance of parents who move a lot
so take a kid in in the armed forces
they end up growing up in different
places you can see does that impact so
there's other ways you can actually get
some random variation where you can
start to get causation out but the raw
kind of data i've showed you so far
doesn't have causal influence in it so
you have some kind of a process
experiment where you can actually yeah
and then there's other you know there's
lots of clues in the literature where
people have looked at sort of you know
random assignment of roommates random
various kinds of things um to sort of
get at these things on some small levels
um getting big scale causal evidence is
pretty difficult and so you know i think
these are suggested and then the models
can give us reasons why we should expect
this to all hang together i think it's
useful you know
these are important policy issues and so
people are doing policies anyway and so
at least this gives us some
way of understanding what might be good
or bad policies um at least you know
what kinds of things matter and why
there might be problems even if we don't
have causal imprints yet
but there's a big it's a big issue in
this literature
especially since the networks are
endogenous right there
okay so just in terms of referrals
mattering i mean this is an old
literature going back to myers and
schultz george schultz are our former
secretary of state and mark granovetter
famous sociologist so a lot of people
have worked on this topic
so you know it matters and there's
causal inference on this so you know if
you you get a random roommate assignment
and your roommate is
better has better outcomes you end up
having better outcomes so there's
evidence of that random refugee
resettlement into areas with
existing populations that have better
outcomes end up having better outcomes
there's uh
studies of random assignments to
military units and then your future
friends
um employment predicts you know a fairly
large spillover in your probability you
end up being employed
um so there's a lot of of evidence that
this matters
um the peer pressure stuff we saw
yesterday right so if we have a a
network which has this kind of strong
homophily it's very easy to have
equilibria if people if the teens are
following the majority of what their
friends are doing it's very easy to have
them choose not to go to college when
another group is choosing entirely to go
to college so that's another force
that's happening as a function of these
graphs
and then what i want to spend the rest
of today on is just a simple learning
model to see how these kinds of splits
would affect you know information
getting from one part of the network to
another part of the network
yes
clarification on the connection between
economic connectedness and homophobic as
foreign connectedness means you're
connected with people with higher than
media but all mostly would mean like
you're connected to those similar to
your income
um and what kind of connection did you
see between those two metrics to the
part on economics
yeah so i guess you know a basic way of
thinking about homophobia would be that
there's some bias towards your own you
know populations of other people who are
similar
and here what we've done is we've just
done a
binary cut of the population and called
half of them rich and half of them poor
and just saying how well connected on
the poor to the rich on average
whereas you could imagine
you could actually originally what we
did is we did it by quintiles
you can divide them into fifths with
quintiles it gets harder because some of
the counties have no you know people in
the top quintile or you know so there's
less coverage of sort of so we did 50 50
because you get
more you know it's better but you can do
it on a very granular level so you can
ask you know how connected are people
with incomes between 10 and 20 000 to
people with incomes between 60 and 80
000. you can see all those patterns
around the country
so the the beauty of having 70 million
people is you know you can really fill
those bins even though they're smaller
bins
but we're just doing it on a binary
level
okay so now this simple information
model
and this is what i'm going to do is just
do the group model which is i think a
really beautifully simple
nice elegant model so it's from morris
to groot in the 1970s there were earlier
incarnations of it
in the literature but the group was sort
of the first person to formalize it and
prove some things about it um so similar
to the national media story um so
and individuals and they're going to be
connected by some weighted directed
network so these are going to be the
people you pay attention to who
influence you
and we'll call you know we think of this
as the t stands for trust networks but
it's some stochastic matrix so each
person has a weight one total weight one
going out and it's just allocated you
know maybe 30 to this person 70 to this
person etc so you start with some
beliefs or attitude etc some number
at time zero
in zero one
um you could make these vectors etc but
i'm just gonna deal the with the case
where these are nice um real numbers
just put them in zero one um and then
what's going to happen is
over time
you're going to learn from the people
around you so your belief or your
b at time t
is going to be the average of what your
friends
had at t t minus one
weighted by this t matrix okay so a
really simple situation so you could you
can start like an example here is
there's three
individuals um you know this person puts
half weight on themselves half a person
wait on person one so you can have self
loops here and sort of how much you pay
attention to your own information versus
other people's information
and so there's a weighted directed graph
and it's going to be row stochastic
since these things are always something
to want okay
then what happens is you start with some
initial beliefs so maybe this person
knows about something in the graph and
now we're going to ask you know what
happens over time so the other people
start with belief zero this person
starts with belief one and now they're
going to update
and so you know they begin this person's
averaging a half of a zero and a one
this person's averaging a third on
two zeros and a one and so forth and so
you just go through and this model then
has really nice simple dynamics okay so
it's it's gonna converge in this case to
two sevenths on each
node so each node would have that
okay so you know one interpretation is
beliefs another would be going back to
yesterday's talk about actions you could
think of this as best responses to some
action right so there's you know we're
all trying to figure out what's the norm
of behavior how much food should be
doing something and this is just
i keep trying to best respond to what my
neighbors are doing and then we're just
doing that dynamic okay so that's this
process and and here we get a nice
answer another convergence issue if you
look at this is there can you show that
this this operator to stochastic metrics
should be a little bit contracting so
that it converges to something more uh
so the remember it's real stochastic and
and what i'm going to show you is
exactly that i'll give you a theorem in
just a second on exactly the convergence
properties
um so it will converge in most cases as
long as this is a periodic
so it has a lot of nice features that go
back to markov chain three so you can
leverage a lot of things from my
production
so um this is borrowed from from ben
it's a nice picture of like let's
suppose these people start out with ones
these people start out with zeros this
is the network and
in this case let's just have people
average equally put equal weight you
know if i have three friends i do a
third on each and then if you just go
through time what's happening here is
you know the people who are connected to
others who had the belief one are sort
of you know going halfway and
so there's some people still stuck at
zero and so forth and eventually this is
going to sort of smooth out and what's
happening in this model is it's going to
just keep smoothing until eventually you
know it's everybody's have the same
color okay and that's going to happen as
long as you don't have um you know as
long as this is strongly connected so
there's a path from each directed path
from each person to everybody else and
you don't have uh just even cycles for
instance in the graph you can have a
periodicity in the graph structure so
you could solve the letter by just
everybody according to themselves
exactly so one you know at least as long
as one person points to themselves
that's enough to kill that you know the
periodicity in the graph and we'll
actually give you convergence here so
convergence is really easy to get in
this model
so you have these different
interpretations
um a couple of features of this which is
actually you know people think of this
as a bug compared to bayesian updating
this is strange but compared to human
behavior it seems to be
more predictive so there have been
people doing field experiments comparing
bayesian learning to this to group
learning the group learning seems to do
a better job at least in some
experiments of predicting behavior part
of the reason is for these two things so
let's imagine this person starts out
with a high belief these people start
out with zeros okay double counting well
this this person is going to influence
both of these
and now this person if they were a
bayesian
they would realize and they knew the
structure of the graph they would say ah
well both of these people got influenced
by this person they wouldn't pay as much
attention to that but in this model both
of these people equally influenced that
so it's sort of like you know what's
called correlation neglect in the
behavioral literature the psychology
literature here comes through in this
you know because i'm i can be of
multiple paths that come through to me
so i have that kind of feature so that's
one feature of this model
another feature of this model is echoes
right these people go are now influenced
by this person and then they're
influencing back so my belief influences
other people and then comes back to me
so there's these different forces which
tend to be um there in at least in the
some parts of the literature
okay
so let's say that t converges if the
limit of t to the t
times some initial belief vector exists
for all beliefs
um okay so here's an example of
non-convergence right
you just have this you know people
waiting this graph is just going to
blink back and forth so you can write
down examples but they're fairly
peculiar examples they've got to have
some
specific periodicity structure to the
cycles of the graph
okay
so we'll say that t is aperiodic if the
greatest common divisor of its directed
cycle lengths is one
and
then it's easy to show if you've got a
strongly connected network meaning from
any node you can follow a directed path
and get to any other node
then
t is convergent if and only if it's
aperiodic so aperiodicity is easy to
satisfy as christian was just pointing
out all you need is one person who pays
attention to themselves you're gonna
have that um work and then you're gonna
get convergence so it's a very simple
model that's gonna converge fairly
generally
um well i mean that's part of the
definition is here you're converging
convergence means that you have a single
limit a well-defined limit
applied to b it's still a vector yeah
it's still a vector and basically what's
going to happen is everybody um
in fact everybody's going to have the
same belief so there's going to be a
consensus as well
yeah so
um here here uh yeah it's not direct
from this so first of all you're going
to get to
some limit
then
also
t is going to be primitive
so that means that
eventually
the all so when you look at t to the t
all the entries are positive
after something which means that
indirectly i'm eventually getting
information from everybody
so you've got a primitive matrix
then you're going to reach a consensus
meaning everybody's
actually believing the same thing and
this consensus is going to be the
determined by looking at what the
initial belief was and looking at the
eigenvector centrality of individuals in
this network and then hitting that
eigenvector times the beliefs okay
um and and i can give you
i don't have quite time to give you a
heuristic proof of exactly why you get
the consensus but i can give you the um
i'll give you a intuition for it
and then then there's another question
a matrix of stationary distribution so
all the roles are the same
as a vector of stationary
exactly so exactly so exactly what it is
you just leverage a lot of markov chain
theory in this model because it's it's
basically almost like
it's sort of like a flipped you know an
inverted markup chain so it has all the
same properties and there's a lot of the
theory there and basically what is
happening is t to the t is converging to
um
a matrix that has all the rows being the
left-hand side eigenvectors here
normally it would be the right-hand side
on a markup chain but it's just reversed
in this case
so you know part of the i mean just the
intuition for this is given a strong
connection you can sort of think about
who has the smallest belief in the
society
well whoever's got the smallest belief
you know either connected to somebody
with a higher belief or they're
connected to only people with a smaller
belief but eventually there's somebody
with a smallest belief connected to
somebody with a higher belief and their
belief is then being dragged up because
they're averaging
and so you know the smallest belief has
to be moving up the highest belief has
to be moving down and since this is a
linear matrix which is a constant matrix
we're not changing the matrix over time
then they're always moving by discrete
amounts so when you look at that then
the limit is going to converge
nicely
okay so you get a consensus here
um
and then the thing about homophily is
going to be can we understand the speed
of this convergence how fast is this
happening and why do we care about speed
well you know a lot of information when
you think about it how long do you talk
about a particular topic if you heard
about an opportunity or something oh
there's a scholarship available you
might tell your friends you might tell
them for but you know after two weeks
you you stop telling them so if this
convergence doesn't happen reasonably
quickly for a lot of information it
means that that information is just not
going to make it and so speed of
convergence is actually important here
and homophily is going to lead to slower
convergence
okay
and so basically if we think about um
you know a network where we have
different types of people take a
stochastic block model take a fairly
segregated network and put all the
information in in some group but not the
others
then you know we'll eventually get
convergence but it could be that you
know even after quite a few periods
there's a bunch of these individuals who
are are going to be relatively
uninformed
okay so that's the reason we care about
the speed
okay
so what does the speed look like um
from markov chain theory you can do this
from sonata
um generically
if t is strongly connected and a
periodic with second largest eigenvalue
lambda 2
then there exists constants
such that
for all beliefs the eventual belief
minus the belief at some time t
is less than or equal to
c times lambda 2 to the t
right so how far away you are from where
you're going to eventually be in terms
of the convergent beliefs
is bounded above by
the
lambda 2 to the t and moreover it's also
bounded below
so we can find some
set of beliefs for which we're going to
be at least as slow
as this parameter okay
so that says if you've got a really high
second eigenvalue
then that means you're going to converge
very slowly
so there's some beliefs that you can get
for which
it's going to take a long time for this
to converge okay
and again
you know
uh just a quick
people
some of you probably know this fairly
well but let me just give you
then i can write there but i'm just yeah
i should point there and then so i want
to give you a um yeah that would be a
disaster right um so
why is it that uh we're getting this
convergence here to lambda2 um
so
take t
and basically
you can write
right so
you can write a matrix
if it's diagonalizable
as
past
these are
these are actually the left-hand side
eigenvectors
right hand side
so there's a matrix of just a matrix of
eigenvectors
this one and then if you want to look at
what t to the t looks like
it looks like this thing
to the t
so for by diagonalizable matrices
um this is a simple way of writing these
things
so you've got zeros here and then you've
got these here lambda to the t
it's going to look like
all these things to the t
this matrix is stochastic so this the
rows sum to one
that means this thing
is one
so what this limit eventually looks like
is governed like how close you are to
the limit eventually these things are on
the second largest eigenvalue is going
to be below one this thing is going to
converge to zeros
and so how quick you get there is how
quick the second largest one is getting
to zero
so if this thing is really big
then that's going to move you really
slowly
okay
so big second eigenvalue slow
convergence small second eigenvalue this
thing's going to look like zeros pretty
quickly you're going to get to that
limit very very quickly okay so that's
sort of a hand wavy proof but you can
actually make that formal and
that's the way that these
things something much more local so you
have the u.s
i don't know what
but i don't care about that i care sort
of what my local number two around new
york is whatever
exactly and so actually um in the in the
data we released we released the
spectral homophily for each zip code
each high school each college so you
just look at this you can look at the
subgraph of that area and then look at
how connected those are and you can look
at those lambdas and then see what they
look like and then see how they govern
the mobility and so forth so that's
something released i'll tell you a
puzzle and an answer to that in a moment
but yes you can you want to look at that
on whatever your you know relevant
network is in order to see where things
okay so so we've got this convergence
being governed by the this lambda 2
and then uh you know for instance in
this network lambda 2 is 0.99
so that's really really slow convergence
right if you put all ones up in this
part of the network it's going to take a
long time for the ones to get down here
okay so now i'm going to tell you about
a result yeah
do you know what's still along the two
put in the community
i don't i don't know i don't know when
you if you start looking inside the
communities um what the what the lambdas
would look like inside those it would be
interesting
um
yeah yeah that's a good question i'm
guessing that that's much lower but you
know there could be additional cuts in
some of these i know for instance in the
india india you know you get additional
sub journey when you look at the
johnny's inside you get these additional
cuts and so it keeps cutting on this one
i don't know
okay so let's look at a very simple
first block model and then i'm going to
give you a relationship
with work with ben between homophily and
this lambda 2. so let's just take m
equal size groups make it the simplest
possible homophily model we can have you
have some probability of connecting to
somebody with in your same group
compared to somebody is different and
generally we'll think of the ps as being
bigger than the pd
so that means you're homophobistic how
big it is compared to pd tells you how
homophobistic the society is
and then let's let p be the average um
connectedness in the society
okay so you know this is would be drawn
from a symmetric block model there's
four different types and they have
higher connectedness within than across
okay so that's a simple model
um let's
make sure that p of n is bigger than log
squared
n over n
so it's a little bigger than the usual
connectedness
but that's going to
give us additional um bites and and
looking across communities
um and then let's just bound
how homophobistic it can be so we're not
gonna allow for
uh too
we're not gonna allow the the network to
completely um bifurcate we'll put a
bound on that
and then just look at a simple case
where you you equally await all your
friends so you don't have some friends
that are more special than others
okay
so from a paper with ben 2012 let's let
uh homophily measure
be the difference between your same
connected probability compared to your
difference probability
and let's uh normalize that by your
average probability so let's look at how
different you are compared to you know
what's the probability of same versus
different
um
theorem that then lambda 2
this homophily measure converges to
lambda two and probability okay so
basically when you're looking at this
lambda two um the homophily measure in a
stochastic block model is gonna tell you
what that um that that lambda two that
second largest eigenvalues
uh
sorry yes zero yes um
no uh yeah yes yes yes that should be a
zero yes definitely
okay
um then you can also do consensus time
so
let's look at
the minimum
so look at some epsilon
and look at
what's the worst belief
in terms of how long it takes you
to get within epsilon of where you're
eventually going to get
so you know the beliefs you could get
you can put all kinds of different
beliefs on the network we can ask how
long does it take you to get to that
eventual consensus
and so this is a measure of consensus
time for some trust matrix that we've
got
we can ask how how long does it take to
get within epsilon of the limit okay
um
then
another theorem is the consensus time is
within a factor of two with the
probability going to one of log n over
um
log of the homophily minus it because
this is a number smaller than one
so the log of the homophily actually
tells you something about
um what the
uh
the consensus time looks like
and for people who we have there's a lot
of people here know a lot of random
graph theory if you know about average
distances in graphs average distances
usually look like log n over log of the
degree here you're getting
this consensus time the speed of
consensus looks like log n over log of
the homophily
basically
so there's sort of an interesting um
comparison there
um you know there's other things you can
prove so this is like a really
restricted version of this the
um we had a sort of follow-up paper
where we said much more about
measures of homophily and you can do
much more general measures of hemophilia
but the homophily seems to look a lot
like this the second eigenvalue does
pick up sort of the worst cut in these
graphs fairly well
mostly measure h of n
versus uh second eigenvalue or the kind
of acting isoparametric type of edge
extension do you have a kind of relation
up about yeah
um
uh so we have tighter bounds in the
second paper
where we can actually show exactly how
these bound and
i don't
know i think it's actually related to
modularity as well um but i don't know
um the precise relationships i'd love to
hear more references in the particular
one you're thinking about
um
but yeah this is something else because
it says to do the second one it's just
eigenvalue versus edge expansion ratio
and
mostly
perhaps related but not quite you know
this cuts of course has to be
edgy expansion properties yes
i don't see the quantitative
relationship no it's a little different
because it's really asking for ratios um
not just the cuts but the relative
ratios of those compared to the links on
the other parts of the graph
because the weights are asking
the
results
they are cheaper like there are cheaper
like results on that but they're so with
the chica
that means
uh
just in terms of keeping us on time then
um so what do we have
homophily is a pervasive human
phenomenon
um it seems to strongly predict economic
outcomes
and
uh and again predicts here
an equilibrium structure of names on
networks opportunities learning all of
these things seem to be in situations in
which these cuts matter and they're
simple models in which you can quantify
the relationship between homophily and
then speed of outcomes on a graph and so
it seems to be an interesting thing for
further study and then um
one last comment uh you know we actually
look at spectral homophily in the
in the facebook data
and it turns out not to be that
predictive of
the income whereas the uh you know the
eventual mobility but it turns out that
the
economic connectedness is highly
predictive and so we wonder like what's
going on there
i think the answer to that is
when you look at spectral homophobia
sort of the worst cut in the graph it
doesn't necessarily fall along income
lines so most places in the u.s tend to
have high spectral homophily you can
find some dimension on which people are
split
but it's not it could be like you know
republican democrat split but maybe not
a long income split and so
when you find really split graphs that
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to have immobility or you know
this kind of lack of income stuff you
need that to be happening among the rich
and the poor and so it seems to be that
then this was what christian was saying
is sort of you know you want to be
looking at the particular cuts that
you're interested in those are the ones
that that matter and so homophily you
know might not be reflected through the
the you know just this
basic things in the graph you have to
look at the labeled graph to see what
the what you want
i wonder if you look at the lower
dimensions of
the the spectrum further down and uh
whether you recover some of other
partitions of interest
yeah i mean so um yeah definitely when
you know the the further um cuts in the
graph will come out of those other
eigenvectors and eigenvalues
and
uh
you know here given that the first one
tends to be so high it can be that some
of the other ones would give us
information about whether or not there's
good secondary cuts or whether there's
just one split in the human society um
but we haven't looked in the data i
haven't seen much difference you know in
in the theory the theory's mostly
asymptotics and so i know that it
doesn't pop in that quickly
but you can get more
exact expressions for how these things
are converging based on that whole
spectrum
it seems that in all of the models you
have described the
the ad ways are fixed right
do you have any idea of like
the where the graph where the attribute
is yeah so there's a bunch of models
that people have looked at where you
adjust these things over time for
instance one example would be that they
just die out over time
you know once i've talked to my
neighbors three times i stopped you know
listening to their beliefs so you can
have those things decay over time or you
can have people so one other model is um
i i tend to put more weight on people
who have beliefs that are high and more
close to mine so if somebody has belief
close to mind then i will move and
depending on what those rates look like
and what assumptions you make about how
that matrix moves you can get different
kinds of results in terms of whether
things converge to consensus whether
they don't whether you can get five
locations
so there's a whole series of variations
on the root model
so
when you
try to analyze network data and you have
covariate data okay so in the social
network anything that's not the
network's currently where people like
text or tweets or whatever so
something that i've seen in predictive
analysis is that that your prediction
performance
based just on the covariate data it's so
good that you can basically throw away
the network
is that something you see here too that
there's such a strong signal like with
your homophily if i had just had that
other signal
yeah so i mean i think
um at least in terms of you know the
the basic ones we've looked at like in
the facebook just saw the exact
opposites right yeah we saw here that
in fact in this particular case you need
the enabled network so one thing it was
interesting it's like when you look at
these ones you look at these other kinds
of things like how they fall unique
to you
those are not those are not various
right those are like exterior data that
county level designers are correct or
something like that
um
right so i guess the question of yeah i
mean i i don't know the right way to
quantify the data
you know in a way so one thing we can
say um just as an
um two different high schools
uh
one large and one small
small high school so small high school
being less than 100 students and another
one more than a thousand students
dramatically different homophily with
the same
characteristics of the students so we
actually go through different
comparisons on high schools and you know
looking at pretty much demographically
identical sub-sample of a high school
you'll get a much more connectedness in
the small school so it seems to be
something also about the institutional
details or the organizational structure
around people that matters
but i think we're past
yeah we have to stop
but yeah we can talk more about it i
think it's an interesting question
yeah yeah sorry sorry yes
thank you
thank you yeah yeah
[Applause]
this is
five minutes